quand le confinement est arrivé c'est
arrivé de façon assez brutale quand même
concrètement nous avons du jour au
lendemain perdu la totalité de nos
revenus parce que c'est un revenu
quotidien
ils font partie des grands oubliés de ce
confinement
les travailleurs du sexe et parmi eux
une grande majorité de femmes
ce sentiment d'abandon n'est pas nouveau
depuis des décennies elle se bat pour
une meilleure reconnaissance de leur
métier
[Musique]
l'une de leur première action
d'envergure c'était en 1975 80
travailleuses du sexe investissent
l'église saint-nizier à lyon de
revendications l'obtention d'un statut
pour leur métier et l'arrêt des
répressions policières
un mot d'ordre de grève a été lancée et
des tracts sont distribués aux passants
chaque jour il précisait l'on nous
accable systématiquement de procès
verbaux fichiers illégalement
nous sommes des prisonniers arabi
les années passent et la situation ne
change pas à la fin des années 90 elles
n'ont toujours pas accès aux droits
sociaux
pourtant les travailleuses du sexe et
les impôts j'avais énormément aux impôts
la mesure exacte palais minimum en 2003
coup dur alors que le racolage actif est
déjà interdite c'est au tour du racolage
passif d'être puni par la loi
deux mois d'emprisonnement et 3750 euros
d'amendé
c'est un nouvel obstacle dans leur quête
de reconnaissance deviendront le peuple
de la bim parce que nous serons dans
l'ombre donc fragilisés en butte à
toutes les délinquances possible parce
que dites vous bien que une fille qui va
essayer de faire ça de manière très
discrète cachées etc
mais elle amère si elle à la merci de
n'importe quel maître chanteur en 2009
elle fonde un syndicat du travail sexuel
le strass c'est une première en france
est une manière d'être mieux écouter
elles sont environ 200 adhérentes
prostituées transcripts yeuse tout
dénonce la chasse dont elles sont
l'objet
malgré ce syndicat toujours pas de
statut à l'horizon en 2016
c'est même un nouvel obstacle pour elle
si le racolage n'est plus d'interdît
c'est au tour du client d'être
sanctionné 1500 euros d'amendé et
jusqu'à 3750 euros en cas de récidive
n'est contre la pénalisation des clients
parce que celle ci va entraîner une
précarisation des travailleuses du sexe
et qui dit précarisation des
augmentations de la clandestinité
augmentation des violences eurent
mentation de l'exploit de l'exploitation
aujourd'hui les travailleuses du sexe ne
bénéficient toujours d'aucun statut
la majorité d'entre elles n'ont droit ni
à la retraite ni à la sécurité sociale
[Musique]